I'm going to in one slide try to get
half of you to walk out of this room
ready ready I am in no way a historian
there you go half the people I love me
in the room you all these Emperor's in
my title and I know nothing about
history in fact all of the history that
I'm going to talk about today comes from
one of two sources one of these sources
is the all-knowing the all powerful the
all great wikipedia right so if you want
to learn more look up late Roman army at
Wikipedia and this will tell you
basically everything I'm saying I
totally didn't make any of it up there
may be some places where you see words
like disputed or other things with
regard to some of the theories i'm going
to espouse you should just ignore those
and pretend you didn't see them the
second place i did is a incredible
podcast series called the history of
Rome who knows the history of Rome there
you go if you have not led read or if
you have not read this podcast good work
if you have not listened to this podcast
and you are looking for a podcast to
entertain you during your much too long
commute I very much recommend this one
it goes from the founding of Rome all
the way to the fall of the Western
Empire it's an amazingly well done
series so if you do want to leave now
because no historians feel free to just
download that and listen quietly in the
back ok so if I am NOT a historian what
the hell am i doing on screen well or on
stage here well my name is Adam I work
for a company called gawa gallows
mission is to create trustworthiness and
critical systems my particular role
there they haven't fired me yet is as a
research in the area of system software
so my goal is to try to make operating
systems network's programming language
runtimes and so forth safer more secure
more trustworthy so that we can build
better systems on top of them that's my
goal so as part of what I do I go around
and I give talks
and because I'm me these tarts tend to
look like this so here is my network
it's full of computers and usually i'm
trying to sell something or discuss
something so a zombie will appear and
then the zombie moves around the network
and bad things happen and I try to tell
people that they should put alarm bells
on their network so they can detect the
zombies okay but every once in a while I
talk to other people who are doing
network defense and I put this picture
up and I say what are the cool things
you are doing to protect your networks
and if i ask that with this picture i
get amazing responses so if i go to
different researchers they'll tell me
about networks ACL so tell me about VLAN
segmentation and sdn work they'll tell
me about mandatory access control at all
levels from the operating system to the
network to the application they'll tell
me about multi-factor authentication
answers and we get this amazing
discussion going if I put up this
picture but I can add one thing to this
picture which destroys all higher
thought you ready there you are as soon
as I put this picture all that cool
stuff that I just talked about all that
cool stuff about VLAN segmentation in SD
ends and off and all that stuff goes
away and if I say what would you do to
protect this network there is one
singular answer put a firewall and if I
say what is the next thing you would do
they will say put a more expensive
firewall and if I even say and then what
would you do then they will tell me
about advanced configuration for
firewalls so why is it that firewalls
and putting this little internet thing
here it seems to destroy all this great
operating systems and network research
why does that thought go out of our
heads well we have this thing in our
culture it's this let's cut them off at
the pass we're always looking for
bottlenecks we're always looking for
join points because we think that that's
how we should defend thing is find the
bottleneck defend the bottleneck and
you're good and we've been taught this
forever how many people in this
audience no the Battle of Thermopylae
pretty good number I guess if you
advertise a hit three talk a bunch of
you know history buffs will shut up all
right next question how many people know
the movie 300 okay the movie 300 is
about the Battle of Thermopylae so now
the next time someone asks you do you
know about the Battle of Thermopylae you
can go yes I saw the movie 300 and you
will be much smarter so the Battle of
Thermopylae was this interesting thing
happened the Persian army was coming
down to invade Greece they had this
massive army massively overwhelming the
Greek forces you can see on this picture
here but at this particular point when
they were invading there was this place
they had to go through where the
distance between the mountains and the
beach got quite narrow so they were
forced to go through this narrow
Junction and the Greeks not being
dummies one mm-hmm I know what to do
about that and they sent the little tiny
army there to defend if you look at the
numbers for this battle it's just
impressive like the Persian army had
just astoundingly overwhelming forces
against the Greeks but at the same time
the Greeks did this amazing job in
defending this thing and they manage to
do all this because they trap them at
that one point at that classic choke
point okay but history can be dry so for
those of it you who did not come here
from the history how many people play
risk okay risk if you play risk for long
enough you will notice a similar thing
which is that you really only care about
certain points on this board and they're
about well they're about those points
you care about those points because
those are the choke points we can get
these massive armies blocked at those
points by these two little tiny forces
just because of you know checkpoints so
it's not a surprise that when you see a
network engineer look at a network like
this that's complicated enough there's
subnets there's nodes whatever and so on
sit how do you defend it they go until
you put the internet there
and then they look and see the internet
and they say oh look at choke point
that's totally a choke point so all I
need to do is put a firewall there and
with my firewall I keep all the bad
people out in the internet and they will
never come back on my network and this
is a lovely idea except for the fact
that is it complete lie so one of the
things I've been doing lately is as I'm
selling a network defense project
product and so I go around to different
IT organizations and one of the things
I've learned and going to IT
organizations is that most sisson mins
when asked how many nodes are on your
network are off by at least a factor of
three so they think they have this
network but they actually have that
Network and who knows how its
interconnected who knows what's there
now some of this is just new stuff
that's come along phones tablets are
connected to the network that they
weren't expecting some of this is old
stuff I went to one deployment where we
did a scan of their network and I think
that they thought there'd be 30 nodes on
this subnet turns out there were 80 and
about 25 of them had telnet open and we
went what the heck are we doing running
telnet on the subnet and it turns out
they had door locks that they had
installed in the late 90s that were some
for some reason telnet access control
that they had completely forgotten about
but we're sitting on this network so
first of all you don't know your own
network and second of all let me ask you
another question there is a strange loop
wireless network how many people are
connected to it ok how many connect are
connected to it with a device that also
has 3g access uh-huh this is not the
picture you have this is the picture you
have
because a bunch of the nodes that you
think are going through your firewall
are not going through your firewall
they're going on through a completely
separate 3g connection and you have no
idea what they're sending and in fact
they could be broken and people could be
tunneling through to your network via
those connections so you don't have a
bottleneck you have a gigantic open
network a huge open border and in fact
this picture I have chosen to draw this
picture because I do not want to destroy
your minds the situation is even more
hopeless than you think I recently did a
little tutorial for a high school camp
of high school students that wanted to
learn about security and I told them the
first thing you need to learn about
doing security for a living if you're on
the defensive side is to give up all
hope right because only through giving
up hope will you understand that what
you're trying to do is delay people as
long as possible and get notifications
right if you try to actually pretend
than protecting that believe that you
are going to be able to do that you will
never win so give up hope my picture was
hopelessly idealistic for those of you
who by the way are thinking my talk so
far enjoying well I work in the cloud so
it doesn't matter because I work in the
cloud you have exactly the same problems
you think you know what the entrance and
exit points are to your cloud that's if
all of your programmers got everything
they did right and in fact all the
operating systems that they relied on
did everything they that right and in
fact the cloud provider got all their
API is right and in fact everyone else
who's running on the same computers that
you're running on in the cloud got
everything they did right now how many
people think that's true that's what I
thought so
when you're defending a network right
now people tend to do this right or let
me put it this way so you may take what
I thought and go okay Adam so what
you're telling me is that if I have a
network and I want to defend my network
what I should do is buy a super
expensive firewall and by the way please
do not walk out of this going this is
the anti firewall talk firewalls are
good you should have them okay but what
I might be asking for is go buy it spend
a lot of money on a firewall and then go
spend a lot of money in a lot of time
investing in subnet defenses to keep
your subnets apart and then go spend a
lot of money going and protecting all of
your hosts deeply so doing making sure
asking links is on make sure you know
that every service that's running on
every machine on your network lock them
down make sure your fire whirls are
going on all that and yes I am asking
you to do this but I do realize one
thing which is that you are not made of
money and you are not made of time and
in some cases you may equate these two
things you are welcome to do that if
you'd like so given the fact that you do
not have an infinite amount of money and
you do not have an infinite amount of
time and you have this huge porous
border and adversaries are out to get
you what are your supposed to do all
right let's hold off on the network
thing for a while let's talk about Roman
history so
roman history up to my hero Diocletian
and his buddy constantine so uh 750 s
roughly city of Rome is funded 509 they
say Kings are bad no Kings we're
Republic we're going to vote people in
as long as their property and have money
in our men okay no Kings 27 BC Julius
Caesar takes over he says I'm totally
not a king I'm an emperor that's totally
different a few years later 80 years
later Empire reaches its greatest extent
under the Emperor Trajan who is second
of the five good emperors that's what
fge is few Emperor's later we get to the
fifth good Emperor which you know is
going to be a problem when there are
five good emperors right so Marcus
Aurelius was number five great guy did a
number of wonderful things wrote a book
on stoicism that is still studied in red
today did a number of things right
except one minor thing which was he
totally chose the wrong successor
successor was a guy named Commodus bad
things happen he kind of went a little
crazy he got himself assassinated we
triggered the year of five Emperor's
which you can imagine if you are an
empire having five Emperor's in one year
not the best thing this eventually
degraded further to the crisis of the
third century we will come back to the
crisis of the third century okay Roman
history in a nutshell you are now Roman
history experts but let's talk about
defense so here is the Roman Empire in
its greatest extent under trajan things
that you might note oh my god that's a
huge border right how the heck did they
defend this border especially there's
some mountains in here that are you know
not shown so there are some places that
you can avoid attacks but you know
there's a lot of land there and a lot of
see a lot of places to get attacked so
early Roman military strategy which i
will use stick figures to describe works
like this every once in while the Roman
Empire would
look north of its border and it would
say gosh that's a lot of people and gosh
they have a lot of money so what they do
is they put together a legion or three
and they would go wander up north they
kick butt steal the money kill a bunch
of people there or enslave them and then
they'd come home and they'd go hey now
there's not a lot of people up there
that's good and we have their money so
what they do is they would say okay a
couple of you you go guys you go watch
the wall the rest of us are going to go
home and spend our money okay and so now
everyone up north is trying to you know
farm to have food for the winter or
whatever even if they do band together
to tag the Romans they come across they
come up to this fort there's still only
a couple people doing there but there's
not that many people attacking them the
Romans can easily overwhelm them and now
they're gone and now they're back
everyone's safe this is how you defend a
huge Empire right easy-peasy no problem
as long as four things are true and
those four things are that you have a
lot more money than everyone else you
have a lot more people than everyone
else you are much better trained at all
levels in your army than everyone else
and you have better technology how many
people have played the game civilization
good people in this crowd as those of us
who play civilization know if you're
going to go invade someone and you have
a giant army of tanks and they have a
small army of horsemen you're probably
going to do pretty well right this is
sort of the Roman Empire approach right
and that's what they did and it works
great but doom I mentioned something
called the crisis of the third century
for a number of reasons that I don't
really want to go into gives us I have
limited time in this talk it was kind of
a crisis the Roman Empire collapses so
it shrinks fundamentally and then
fragments into three pieces a bunch of
bad things happen a lot of Civil War you
get some plague you get trade
descriptions across the entire empire
you get a complete collapse of the
coinage which is not great and basically
bad things happen and they happen for 50
years so
this has on for a while in the Empire's
fragmented until our hero Diocletian who
may or may not have looked like that
bust he gets the band back together Rome
is 11 Empire once again but he is
somewhat wise and goes this is a really
big Empire and I am just one person so
what I'm going to do is have Co
Emperor's and he picked three this is
called the Tetrarchy you learned a term
today so he has some co Emperor's one of
them will eventually be Constantine and
that's why Constantine gets his name in
my title ok so let's go back it's good
to be the early Romans because of these
four reasons but we just went through
the crisis of the third century so we
have no more money we have no our people
because bunch of them died in the plague
and or civil wars we are no more better
trained than our enemies anymore because
they had 50 years to catch up so while
we were fighting each other as romans do
to do killing each other bad bad bad
they were training each other and
getting better similarly their
technology moved ahead while we were
dying so it's no longer really good here
so again back to civilization which
teaches us everything about history you
know if we have two equal forces at the
border now it's a little bit of a dicey
proposition maybe we'll win maybe we'll
lose a not sure anymore so here we are
in the Roman Empire time of diocletian
you'll see a little bit smaller right
but still big long border so we have
here very wide attack service we have no
money and we have lots of enemies to do
do do to do alright so early am so now
we have our room and strategy again ok
so first thing we looked across the
border we see a whole bunch of people
there we look at our legions you can go
no we're not going to go across we might
get killed and if you're an emperor last
thing you need to do lose a bunch of
legions to the barbarians ooh bad
politics so nevermind we don't have that
many people anyway so we're just going
to send some people to the borders and
send everyone else home because we need
them to farm and get food for us so what
happens then
now there is a big army north and they
look down at the roman empire and go hey
it's the Roman Emperor they beat the
crap out of us for years and stole all
our money what should we do so they
gather an army it's much bigger than the
people at the post the people at the
post died and now you've got this army
ready to invade the soft underbelly of
Rome okay this is bad this happened for
a while until Constantine in the
dilation thought hmm there must be a
better way to make this work better for
us so they switched to what I will call
late Roman military strategy and it
works like this well problem statement
always start with your problem statement
don't start with development problem
statement first problem statement we do
not have enough troops to sufficiently
hold the border we can't just fill the
border with troops and and and push back
any invasion that comes we just don't
have that many people and we don't have
the money to pay them even if we have
the people problem number two we don't
have enough Stroup's to even defend our
cities we cannot just stage our armies
in our cities and defend them there
because again don't have people don't
have enough of money so how are we going
to defend our gigantic empire when we
have these this problem we're going to
do this step one are soft easy cities
we're going to build walls around them
so if you have been to Europe or are
from Europe and you have seen walled
cities this is when they started to be
built is right around here step two we
are going to have an army but it's not
going to be enough to protect everyone
but we are going to make it mobile so
it's just going to sit here in the
corner okay so here's what happens now
the barbarian and people they come close
to the wall our guards at the gate go oh
that's more people than we can defend
against so one of them runs over to the
army and one of them runs over the city
and says hey hey barbarians coming
prepare right so now barbarians get to
the gate there's no one there good luck
they kick down the gate get through do
to do to do and they head towards the
city but there are walls there and there
are defensive troops there which means
that they can hold out for at least a
little while
maybe not forever but just long enough
for do to do to do cavalry to arrive
kick their butts don't know no more
barbarians empire saved yay cheer cheer
all right key aspects of this strategy
right your border guard is not there to
defend against all attacks right it can
defend against light attacks drive-bys
if you will no problem but it's just
they're mostly to notify you that an
attack is coming when heavy attacks do
come your goal is not to defend them it
is to know about them as soon as you can
it is to hold together your key assets
for as long as you can and hopefully
long enough for the cavalry to come by
right so let's get back to networks we
are not the Roman Empire especially not
the early Empire we do not have more
money than our adversaries we do not
have more people than our adversaries we
are in fact not much better trained
that's not to say that we are untrained
or unskilled it's that our adversaries
are pretty trained and pretty skill we
do not have a technological edge on our
advertisers if anything quite the
reverse and in fact we are even worse
than the realm earlier that ramen Empire
here because we don't actually know
where our borders are and furthermore
one key aspect of the early Roman
defensive strategy was that occasionally
they left Rome kicked butt for a while
depleted the adversarial population and
then came back turns out I'm not allowed
to do that
so we can't just say hey we're getting a
lot of attacks from this place in
Eastern Europe let's go D das Eastern
Europe people get upset when you do that
so instead of taking sort of the early
Roman apprentice let's think about maybe
it makes sense to take the late Roman
approach so let's translate military to
to technical know about the attack as
soon as possible we call that intrusion
detection in the networking world hold
things together for as long as it takes
for the army to come we call this
defense in depth have an army that can
get to the situs problems as quickly as
possible we call this the agile IT
workforce okay so let's go through each
of these intrusion detection I love this
stat so I included and just about every
talk I give in 2013 a company called
fire re who knows what fire are is okay
they're a company that does basically
network defense and post hoc attack
analysis so if you're if an intrusion
happened on your network they will come
and tell you what happened right they
put out a study in 2013 and which they
do median time in their experience
between an attacker gaining a foothold
on the network and being detected on the
network so how long do you think that
was shout it out okay I've hearing a
bunch of hours and days in a couple
weeks I'm hearing a bunch of smart asses
say a few years and so on what you'd be
interesting is that the few years people
are probably closer to correct than the
few days folks so what they actually
published was 229 days so that's just
shy of eight months that in median terms
so there was a lot worse than that
that's what median means was eight
months 2014 we had learned about network
defense we were much better how much
better do you think we were to 28
anyone else 150 180 is what people are
thinking 228 was a better answer got it
down to 205 so this is bad people right
like we need to know that intrusions are
happening sooner than this there are
solutions to this we need to figure this
out it goes against our engineering
nature to install intrusion detection
software because we kind of feel like
we've lost at that point right why
should we install intrusion detection
software we should just keep the
intruders out duh right let me just tell
you back to an earlier point
hopelessness give up on hope right so
you need intrusion detection software
you should get on board this train I'm
not going to recommend any particular
intrusion detection software except of
course the one that I wrote in that case
you should totally buy something called
cyber chaff it will protect you it's
awesome tell all your friends they
should get licenses okay so intrusion
detection get on board that tells you
that there as an is an adversary on your
network and you need to do something
about it but let's also talk about
defense in depth right now when people
think about their budgets in terms of
network defense what they do is they
look at their budget and they say it's n
dollars and they say what is the biggest
firewall I can buy for n dollars right
and then they install that firewall
right there and I say to you no do not
do that no no different approach look at
the budget that you have by your most
modestly priced firewall a good one but
something modestly priced and then take
some of the money that you have left
over and put that into protecting your
subnets subs not all subnets need to
talk to each other you can program your
routers to do that you should do that
right then if you still have some money
left great look at your most critical
hosts harden them a little bit turn on
selinux make sure your firewall is on
make sure there's no funny processes
running if you bought take any of the
free network scanning tools they will
tell you a lot about your computers for
example there are some major linux
distributions that install
web-based remote administration controls
by default in their default install
maybe turn those off right and then if
you still have some money well protect
some of the other nodes on your network
as well and then if you still have money
buy a bigger firewall and then come back
and thicken your subnet reproductions
and then come back and fix your critical
host and then go back and fix the next
one are you getting the feeling here
sort of a wash rinse repeat thing right
so just spread your money across because
the goal is to get it everywhere
throughout your network so that every
host in your network can hold on against
an attack for even just a little while
and then your intrusion detection
software should tell you that the attack
is there and you can you can handle it
before anything super bad happens so
Roman history and network defense in
summary like Diocletian and constant we
have a long border we have no staff we
have no money and we have lots of
enemies so just like them we need to
detect our threats as soon as possible
we need to spread our defenses across
the network and our goal is basically to
hold together for as long as it takes
for our assistant men's to save our
butts okay good
now in my title I mentioned something
about Bedouin sayings this is another
point I've been trying to make a bit
recently so we have this belief that
network defenses like this we are the
small tiny green node at the bottom and
everyone want else on the network wants
to kill us right this is basically how
we think I want to make us think in a
slightly different way turns out there's
probably a few people in the world that
you actually kind of like right they are
on the network as well you can talk to
them that's what the internet is for
right beyond these people these few
people that you like and trust and
believe in and so forth there are people
that you are paying it is in their best
interest for you to still be around to
keep paying them these are people like
ISPs right you pay them they give you
service they do not benefit if you get d
dost in fact they get hurt too so
they're in it with you and then although
this may con you a great bit of
existential dread there are a whole lot
of people that really don't care about
you at all and then finally there are
some people who are legit out to get you
okay it's not paranoia they are there to
get you so this penny one's saying I
really like a citation needed by the way
I don't actually have a basis for
believing this is beto and accept again
wikipedia which is against my brothers I
and my brothers against my cousins I and
my brothers and my cousins against the
world right we need to take this into
network defense as well you know we need
to work together so that we can protect
ourselves from the enemies out there and
one of the ways I like to talk about
this is that competition does not mean
total war right just because I compete
with for network defense dollars with
some of you does not mean that I'm
planning some sort of elaborate cyber
kinetic attack on your institution to
bring down your company to its knees
trust me I'm not right just because I
compete for research dollars with some
of the professors and grad students in
the room doesn't mean that I'm launching
you know baroque cyber attacks to make
sure your proposal doesn't actually get
submitted to the funding authority on
time we just compete right we don't try
to kill each other and in fact there are
quite a few studies that say if an
attack is against Fergus
Apple this one bank the likelihood that
that attack will be used against another
Bank is actually very high these things
go in clusters by industry and so what
we need to start doing is as industries
say I am competing with you and I am
going to fight you tooth and nail for
every customer you have but at the same
time I'm going to tell you all the
attacks that seem to be coming at me
because then you can protect yourself
and similarly you're going to tell me
about all the attacks that are coming
against you because then I can protect
myself as well right and so we need to
get these collaboration going the
silence that we have right now really
only helps our adversaries so let's
let's talk let's see what goes on by the
way if you're looking for a tart for
next to your strange loop and you can
write a better abstract than I can
here's your talk for next next you it's
called the Hanseatic League and the
Internet I thank my colleague Trevor for
telling me about the Hanseatic League I
read just a little bit about it I think
it would be a really interesting talk
may the best abstract rin again i'm not
going to d toss you it's just we're just
we're just trying to put this up there
right so in conclusion and I'm told by
google translate that both these things
meet in conclusion you can tell me later
how I am terribly wrong or swearing at
your mother's you know in this right
there are three things I want you to
remember number one you probably do not
know your own border and your enemies
are both well funded or bored right
let's be honest you need to protect
yourself against a very long border with
with a very active adversary who's just
as well trained as you so the second
thing I want you to think about is
spreading your protections across the
entirety of your network just you're
putting a firewall on the outside lanes
isn't going to keep everyone out you
need to keep amounted every level in
your network and you need to figure out
where they are and when they are and so
forth wash rinse repeat go through your
entire network and then start again and
do it again until you run out of money
and you're going to run out of money
trust me we always run out of money in
security but do the best you can the
final thing I want to say is you have
friends in the world and you even have
friendly competitors so
we should talk more and we should talk
about more so that is everything I
wanted to say I'm here to take questions
you can email me or tweet at me please
only nice tweets and if you want to
compliment me to my company that's the
company twitter handle you can say gawa
what a great speaker Adam is you should
keep paying him doing thank you thank
you very much again if you want to look
at the history of Rome it's right there
thank you very much
okay I have a question but to you before
I even answer questions which is when is
the end of my time slot 220 okay I've
got eight minutes by my clock you sir
with the wonderful head yep mm-hmm yep
so the question is if you're someone who
is using entirely or primarily managed
services who are supposed to be doing
all this security stuff for you that's
why you think you're paying them what
can you do to improve their security and
what can you do to improve your own on
top of their systems so there those are
actually I'm going to answer that in
those two pieces right so part number
one is you should be asking what they're
doing for security you should send them
evil saying what intrusion detection
system are you using and if they can't
say blank then you don't know maybe you
should think about someone else now let
me put something else there are a couple
intrusion detection systems which do a
really good job but they have really
high false positive rates and so I have
heard from system administrators who are
told for example you must install this
intrusion detection system on our
network so they did and they want yes
boss totally installed it what they
didn't tell their bosses they had set
the output to dev null so it was in fact
technically installed on their network
but they weren't really using it so you
might want to ask them slightly deeper
questions then have you installed it as
in hey how many intrusions do you detect
on a given day what's your what's your
response you know strategy if you detect
intrusion and stuff like that that may
get pushed them to getting in there a
little faster as with all things um
theoretically the open market and
competition should
make security better I say that with a
bit of doubt in my voice and so I don't
know what else to do on that point one
thing I can say is you are paying for
them for security but you're not paying
them for endless securities so there's
stuff that you can do in your
application as well to keep yourself
secure which is this so number one thing
if you want to secure your system okay
are you already cut pens ready
encryption is good everywhere so I don't
care how secure you think these two
hosts are I don't care if you think this
message is only going to stay on the
same host encrypt it using TLS tunnel
using SSL tunnel I know blah blah blah
performance blah blah blah blah blah
whatever which is cheaper that or for
all of your users to have identity theft
protection forever right so encryption
good use it there's a bunch of sites
that will tell you how to use it easily
in a bunch of different languages to
just slop sodden in it works great so
lesson number one use encryption okay
any other questions sir
mmhmm yeah so the question is apparently
a Google research in their infinite
wisdom has decided to are they actually
putting it on the open internet or just
pretend that it's on the open Internet
at least pretend that all of their hosts
are on the open Internet and then defend
them like as they were I think that's
actually as a exercise that's a great
idea you know pretend that your computer
is on the open network addressable from
everyone another little story I was
helping out a little company or
institution I should say and they had a
subnet that they just put all their old
servers on and they had a class b or
Class C publicly addressable thing and
they were like this is just a network
that's off to the side no worries we
don't even worry about turns out a
little bit of a bargain their core
router that subnet was actually open to
the world so anyone anywhere could
access any of those computers in there
emeritus subnet which included things
like heaters so that's an issue so it's
good from a notional perspective to
think maybe this computer is open to the
internet because it might actually be
open to the Internet that being said
again please don't walk out of here
thinking of this as the anti firewall
talk firewalls are great they keep a lot
of what you might call drive-by traffic
out of your network and that's good you
should have them there so that's why
defense-in-depth right that's the
recurring theme here yes pretend it's
opening the internet protect it like it
is but also let's put a firewall there
and also there's some other things we
can do it router level to do cool things
too so let's do that too so do it all do
everything whatever it is you can afford
all right three minutes who has a three
minute question that gentleman has a
three minute question
yep I do not I wish I did because it
would really help my sales efforts but I
don't the only response i have to that
is it is right now seven eight months
right I don't think intrusion detection
is going to make it worse and I think we
can do better I think in our installs
with our product we've shown that we can
detect some very suspicious behavior
very quickly just by doing some simple
things so I haven't seen any published
studies there's a number of reasons why
published studies are hard to do in
defense one of which is that you know i
have a few beta customers right now for
some reason they don't like it when I
publish about you know attacks on our
networks for some reason like they feel
that this will give them bad press and
they might lose sales and things like
that so it gets hard to get them to
publish that information but so now i
wish i could 2-minute question sir so
actually it turns out it's it's really
easy to put in a firewall rule that says
don't let traffic from this IP come in
please or don't let traffic of this
shape come in so it's really about
knowing where the attacks coming from
and knowing that it's there so once you
know that impacts coming there's a
number of things you can do based on
what the attack is if it's just someone
coming in through an IP address block
the address you're done and you can get
very fine-grained at that point so you
don't have to worry about you know
blogging off all of Europe for 15-20
minutes right you can also do things
like if you believe they're on a
particular host so phishing attacks are
the best way for people to get into
networks cat pictures are the doom of
the internet right so as soon as you
know that something is being used as a
foothold on your network you can shut it
down clean it out right and that does
wonders so
there are a number of steps you can you
can take once you know that someone's
there and where they are right many of
the attacks that people are using today
especially it's sort of what you might
call criminal level attacks and below so
people who are in it for the money or
the entertainment value if you will
right are not good enough to install
persistent threats that are going to be
hard to pull off your network right it's
really more advanced people that you
have to worry about that sort of stuff
with so honestly if you know it's on
these computers and it might even be on
this router it's-- favorite trick always
works turn it on and off again and then
maybe run some virus scanners and clean
them off or just do a blank reinstalling
you should be good all right I think I'm
running out of time so thank you all
again for coming